The final issue is incorporating
direct into the physician's workflow.
Earlier I showed you this and
mentioned the share button,
as well as automated import of
the data into the recipient's EMR.
These are examples of how HIT would
ideally be more finely tuned to
support efficient workflow.
Absent them, the sending physician might
have to export the patient chart from
their EMR, start up their email program,
find the exported chart
in whatever folder it was placed, attach
it, address the email, and send it.
That's pretty much the way you would
send an attachment using email.
All of that, except for
addressing email by selecting the
intended recipient, could be automated.
At the receiving end, a similar but
essentially reverse
process could be avoided.
Moreover, were the attached
patient summary in XML,
as we suggested earlier, it could
be parsed, so that, for example,
Marla's blood pressure, pulse, heart
rate, blood sugar level, and so on,
could into the appropriate fields
in the recipients EMR, saving still
more time and eliminating potential
sources of transcription error.